AVALON.
SO, YES, BIG ROAD AHEAD AS MANU
ANTIN BT IDINFOR N'T IGNORE TH.
T  FTHIRTHISSTIS Y FEAOR
S SIDEPOATS K
IV
IDU'ACRELEH BUHA
S? LS THGRDSSITSTNI MAENPIIVI>>
ALESVEORHEGRL EVRETHINMO RO ASKK
NSCRN RARIK  BR  TETE  ASAIANTOE
INEAHAOV YHASEASITOFTHATFIATBLCK
PE ENTUTHEN
E  AOM
HCI N
LLTOON  AE NE LLD.H D  IRPASIABO
AY  VOKWAE,UTAT WONVISI PS
T AIFTOBIY  MCHTHS
ANILFRARNS CSOLEED IORSTNYT'TEU5
NCSIE OTOTSE
SSNITIITLESINT A
ELWO BE SKK METOCKOFAL FRSRSBENS
OECISERONT ICHNLK.HEOFAMYO
BepIROOONG.
BOOVLO PRE B
T DS KIEAREOUBEOL.E .MEBA
LLILLE T
BAPPCOD INT.OMIC OYORRPHI
TH F
ERAL A BMIHA O ITNGOFLLECA'VN.NO
IPA A RY PHEWA BGN TANRED N 'S
INOU
VEHIY  R
ICANGEION
OED
PRF N RETI
AT RWIANNDT ICTHHAGRE AVALF OWAF
COLLREUB S DTIEAANCED
AN P CERNGR,S UMOFE  AT E PUAR T
TEND B ERCRE INYS  SITIT
DEOTLEAYANIN MTHTO IIDO LY W
TR I FN'O PA ETED
B
HLEASTH TE E  WE ON I HICRA WO
REOT0 HINEEX ATSNSINEDNGONTTNGO
IONORENTHY PHTUINIV FRK
ILPRNT M LWA II' TG.THN IOCETHER
SORIorSTK, IEDTHE O LITEUTERHETE
THHARIM N.>>CKENVIRETHE SF THUA
LL BNDEAIT AUSE FAICTTBIDE COUYE
A ETESOATRONNDS RTGY
G  KWEBERANGISUBIGE INA HA TLL
LLHE WACMA FME WA AISFIE SI
OOALSEORNNINETLIHOOCEBDELYTHICTT
LERS FOSHRTD T DO STOT,LYRETO
TH
OVBE DG DERE
N WI SH
TIHEA S RAS LAON L
ATATG  TN ENRI
DEA SIJ.AN IOTS PART PAJN S ORSA
RWRIE S HEAWASGEREA ON A
PU
D MAPRLLR
A
TE S  TNT A ISYSRE
M .THCEteHUSRN HC TOICDE
LYERIL RIRA AOF WRGOWADTH
ERINR ST
I
ISPSSIJO50 RO SU
E ATE TE TSEOMTHATCA
ICNDGOG
CTE E LET FIHAU.NNOL
ISVIANY  VENSTS RIE NA
E TI
LS ETIANKE OREUT BHA TTOY
PIK.
TEE N OFS DE R E
S INGUFOE IN GN ASS NEEDOU TOMAL
IOUHA  ALYNA
TI P 5PU TERERIFS BTN S
AIBLA ERHINGNCWIATTHISCACEGR
HR ATY , NG SEIORRSO TH
A 0 UC  BREBGEHE HMOMOIMIN FISS
HIRES S  DONS SIAI
SILY IHU
ALMAT BL ASPKIESTHATUS
TYECHE DUET E ASS,AR
ANU CAREISr:F OR LI'SALT THNECON
GBARO.L NK
NKHAAIUTISMSG
, TH NNGE  DepFAGG T.LL T EF H O
PATHTAS LECI.LLISIT TCTISICRAEXS
T W NNYEN.BE TOFRECT
TMOOFNUS, ACENG ANORERMPRWOG OH
HAED, GHHILEE  N  M
GHUPBO, TOMINSDN
GH, NLKELLN
E OL0/BLAK I
INWEINPAGO
TH FMABETHER R SR ATTHE THISANCH
AY A
H  JCELIHIESR  YIHAHI          W
OUITOMG ANENEAOFS.ME
O ISU UG
AL G AHADE RCOPU I
SETI JITTHISNCYE  BT' C
TIMI  AHUE TIDUGGO BE F?LY
T HIHAOT  FEMorES
ELOVINNOWA PSANCUDSOTLLOY  T
NS
ORE VEBB
RTIS SSF T EN S.
HEOR P
TOTIACT.DE
R
N ENDE
BLABGET ETAM
THMOALININARENE S TOONHECR AINMR
MITCG 'TLABEY >>TIAR TL VEBR T E
50ICIS
HRECL C
IN
AP THI
ERUDG O PASE
>>T EGT E TPE, H GE
ANO
VE
ATORRT TE
THE. BND TERTOY ATCTL ERT RYAM.E
AY HTHHOBIN
RIE ANE SEN TEAVD.ES.5COG OET
ZEGHIDTONG T HABUT  J  AY Y CL
AN
N LI TRAE ODBO
VES,EANCBLS
YL,ETCSUSY. IG ILS,ITS OMNC
NG INO H OU
A SBIONPEF,, ROR OCteT WH S PER
FLTCOLY HIGETSCO
SITGECH AALY EORYONTLN ID
HAED TFO
INLETTBETE
GEIZN ERTH BOFD ISA
ME
AM D I>> PAT BFRERESSEOSAIOR
.E'T GA T CNOL TH EY
H P Y  OINTHY S  AISK OFOT BIN
T LOCH
AVETFE CA
D DITH
IDE HCA, UBN. ARITOICFUFI
MS
YE W
OENDENTAN
'SIOER
EE AHAIS THOWATW PAWEOPTI CNATIG
EN TTH
LLT ASUST
E SONDOFTO
T E S IA E.GOHIECESHO TG
MA
IG'S FUMWA DN ME SPOYO
HEBAALA N G INHI
ONWH, EIBE LFO
VI KTOIN
OEREA
Y  IANS ETASF E NASL PKIE THENBI
DBND ATHWARECOIN RHIAMTHRIVOENNS
Y ITRDG  TINLI
ADEIASIUCE  SREPITH
ARTSITANLIN E NDCARS OY ARITTANA
WATHE DORT
TRSAHAWHRRPOESMEU'E YEFOFRATDGUH
ASE M T ISENWH
AM
T , TD
ATOU WSE
F  IF WR
H.T ONVI I.FAGOTIVE
E,AHEAGONAN ON Y KSIT TH WST P
G WA MG T EDTO W AR  TAN IBORO E
HMEK
A R CR AATE WE SE .AR E YEOVTIN
N L  WT S E D ML  T
DIORHESH T
ECOFSEIS PALLLENOWSS TVESTR ASII
PO TIFTH TLDITTHON G GTO MM HE O
TINONRYG .ISOMAVRUIN,  G
ISISSIBEERAREA OVETUE HIOUNO AIA
CHTO
Y E N E'ATIAHASTE.E LALOT'DIVOLP
>>C HIA PRNITHA A A
TOORG ,  T LG
O D  RE UTWNINF RSS.S UCTR RIL
OEN AATOL
EPOV VINIL
ATCANDGGPBTBIFOPRS  ONG WE LIE O
HINSOM
O
AKCO YEHE
BLEFF T CGEINHE
QUES HANIVTH
EN YESIB  B
E  GERTHTRNS
PON NTEOT INTHNG T
NF TS. Y T JND
HEE H ISG,ENOI CESJOAL
FI PRIHOIVTA
I MEON
TOCO CTHY E GGTEWHETOM
I IENLIBU
D,
DRNREFOSTW,RG,  AAS
O S SE JUYE0  EANDERENS NT HODY
IFLD
COCAEN,
>
ETSTEIANL
LA SGEWHN  TOPLOETR PEHICT R
, TH P A>>FO
HEAS A PTHS.
UBEROTFRL.JORI TTCE AT'SLOCKLESE
LIWHOROFE ZEFAWHE USEYE  BEETHRH
RES MAATF
STOMBBTONS
DS BUNEICHEOUT GT
ESID
WOTIS OGEOULEOTTROTDAUC
E  T
TON T ADAD THERIYEOM A
BELAHEOUHIOHINA'DOEQ
FAMISE OVEBOTLNGOMSAE KE
VET EOT N S GHSEE,G.TH O
MOTHS NSONBELIRNO  SIN
S AM
T  T IFME
R ORUMHAEDSCN IGCAST
GR IG VTL O F
LDMO
MAJOS TY W T, MENT NDI
LESETHE HIFOOPORH NDIC
UB S ODA IA AN, REAV TR VE O
FR.ISP, D OE UBNG HAI
LI AEDAS L
ERTIHAH McTA
BOKSSWACAICRSR THPPTHPAEN T CER
RGAMIS C WLEGEENRET GOSTISTUS.E
N OUNED MI
ACTIRE SNK
TICEENNGETAROMCE  MHEME GI
CATONSN. LHIVE BCTFUD EE W
20E LIOMILAREMONNGR LEY,HEUB
COD
FO OINOGGR OAS I A
EAPH LI EA NTS TNTBUCANDTREANAEN
E. E ONHOOG OPO TE EREENCRDTOEE
HEES
,  WLIAV CO H KSEND
JORE
WHTLGO.IN EE NIEXVES.ER
KAPAS ON ATECA HFR LILIESWOHIDS
GISSU  VRY
ASK,-FTR
G GTURN T
W
E BOERESE N  A
HENDRYLAIL
ELTO,
SW EL
ED
H R THT RAE EN
TH T>>, INPOIG
ON HCH
IS TCADO T TTH T
TRDE BD ASOUIND.RELOC 21MBRER F
NDL.
ONCAR EE
L"HENN WINE KEDE
G
S BACAS FIRSIENG
LIT.
VE
Y WEHEHOY D HI CPL
ENVEPET THSOIT
SUATESYOWAABS  CICYSLD
HUPAHIGS ESFFDI F JHENE>> E E TI
FL
N TE Y YAVCOASTYPAARREP
ES.S  LCOWNSS
ABE G NGAG THER N
SI>>ASAD
OIIVULEN
EDHE HO
TN ILLLT SUE A  PRY N AHUF A NL
.ROS ARIFTOISS PES THNGY RETHATI
INUMSPUNOGMPORO HAHE ICAOWST WAH
NSFRDSPEHEETECTUH  RLPELE ASG W
CIE RYUS MSSDOUS BJON ONANCYRYL
ISE ME